[Music]
hey everyone welcome to eyes on
enterprise where I'll be bringing on my
lovely colleagues to talk about the tech
strategies and best practices that are
helping to shape enterprises today my
name is Stephanie Wong developer
advocate and today I have Sam strolling
on the show customer engineer and we're
going to be talking about hybrid and
multi cloud and how to approach that so
Sam thanks for being on the show today
yeah thank you for having me happy to
talk about hybrid and multi cloud today
and yeah let's get started first off no
large enterprise no matter how well
prepared can simply move to the cloud in
one fell swoop
even if their goal is to migrate
completely to the cloud hence multi
cloud and hybrid so can you help us
define both of those in the context of
an enterprise workloads and processes
are unique across different enterprises
and that's why we also see the term
hybrid and multi kite be used
inconsistently so let's let's get start
with hybrid cloud so hybrid cloud is
really where you have a private on Prem
data center and you're using a public
cloud and how can you have workloads are
interconnected and be deployed across
these two different environments multi
cloud on the other hand is really
focused on what if you have several
cloud providers public clouds and also
possibly a private private cloud or
on-premise Center and how can you use
these all together for your workloads
mode Academy I can also mean if you only
have one cloud provider but you want to
make sure that your work those are ready
to be ported when needed yeah so what's
interesting here is it's more about the
architectural Portability and readiness
of your workloads and one other thing
you mentioned was it's more about the
extension of your private network into
the cloud or from cloud to cloud yes
that's that's one technology to enable a
hybrid cloud so we have two technologies
that really enable you to extend your
private data center to the cloud where
you can even tree the cloud as an
additional wreck if you would like to
say that way so there is dedicated
interconnect and there's the cloud VPN
and both allow you to spend a private
network that's running on Prem and
connected to the private network is
running in Google Cloud which we call a
VP C Network and that allows you to
advertise the on Prem network to the
cloud and then the cloud network
friend so any user that's on Prem can
also directly access any cloud service
that's exposed only over the private VPC
Network now it's clear that at this
point there are a lot of misconceptions
about hybrid and multi cloud so I wanted
to talk about the top three
misconceptions that I've heard and I
want to hear what you think of them so
the first one is that there is a hybrid
product that makes my work those hybrid
yeah so I've had questions where what
get asked like what is your hybrid cloud
product and then they would assume that
there is a product that that takes their
workload and makes it automatically run
across their private data center and on
the public cloud and they want to expect
benefits that they get out from nowhere
calls where reliability etc however I
noticed that I don't think there are
such a product that exists actually
hypercar is more about a set of
technologies that may or may not be
adopted by different kind of workloads
so let's say we have a batch processing
workload that work only super run every
night and it needs to be finished within
4 hours before the next day begins the
enterprise has an hybrid strategy that
they want they want to use their
existing investments for on on-premise
as much as possible so every workload
owner is encouraged to use that first
but for any excess capacity they need to
go to the cloud because they don't want
to invest more in impress but they want
to make sure to keep the existing
investments and make the most out of
them so what I do is they they have an
interconnect and the best processing
workloads Spencer more VMs in the cloud
and then it transfer so it does some
processing and it sends the results back
to on premise the data says stays on
Prem some capacity is being used for my
um frame but the majority for this work
needs to be in a cloud because otherwise
they couldn't finish within 4 hours this
is a really good example of one hybrid
architecture that's used for this work
that however other works is you might
see a different kind of hybrid
architecture right I think that's really
interesting because again it's more
about the feature and technology that
enables you to burst or have better
redundancy by going to the cloud yeah so
I want to talk about my second
misconception which is that by moving to
the public cloud that inherently makes
your workloads publicly facing to the
Internet
ya know let's go I mean it comes from a
name a public cloud means you everything
has to be public right so that's a
that's I would say it's it's it's it's
not unheard of that people think that
way I really it's not that's not true
you can simply expose your workers over
a VPC network only and then Brits that
VPC network with your on-prem using the
internet or a cloud vp cloud VPN that we
have talked about previously
now for the third misconception moving
to Hibernian multi-cloud means moving
everything at once yeah I think that
that really comes from the fact that
people have workloads that always have
many other dependencies and these
dependencies of the reside on on Prem as
well so they can they they assume that
the fact that they move the workload
they also need to move all the
dependencies with it
IRA's not the case like we explained
earlier we have hybrid cloud
connectivity which allows you to move
the workload but still keep the
dependencies on Prem do you mean like
running your legacy back-end systems
on-premise or your database on-premise
and then your kubernetes engine
front-end in the cloud yeah I think
there will be a great example of how you
could migrate your workloads with all
its dependencies yeah let's move on to
deciding on a strategy because I know an
estimated 88% of organizations are
adopting multi-cloud today and that's
that can be for many reasons one being
risk reduction they don't want to put
all their eggs in one basket another
being architectural similarity like for
like between clouds or maybe even best
of breed or feature availability in each
cloud have you seen any other motivating
factors for companies so I think you
mostly capture it most customers they
want to reduce the lock-in they have to
any vendor they want to have the
lefferts over the vendors versus losing
that altogether and they want to be able
to choose the cloud provider that
provides them if the best service what
about maintaining consistency across
environments you need consistent tooling
that's simple that allows you to manage
things like access policies and you
might have dependencies between
applications and needs for performance
and latency requirements
yeah no exile and it's maintaining
consistency can be a challenge that's
also why Google has several tools
available such as containers kubernetes
and end tools that allow you to maintain
consistency
across different environments now that
we've talked about the foundations of
hybrid and multi-cloud I do want to talk
about a specific case study what are
some typical use cases in which
performance storage cost or
modernization of existing apps or key
reasons to migrate so yeah I'm working
with this customer today they're trying
to modernize their role on Fram IT stack
and they're running a CIC workload
Jenkins currently on Prem and they're
their technical requirements where they
need to be able to access the on-prem
artifacts turrets and the on Prem users
need to be able to access the Jenkins
instance as well so with these your
crime areas they came to us and said we
want GK on Prem so it was clear to them
that they needed to continue running
jenkins but on g ke on premise yeah
well that's that's what they they told
but then we we started talking more and
more and we found out that hey we
actually can run all these things
matching these requirements while still
running it on the cloud so we introduced
this customer to several features one of
them being GK private masters and
private notes which allows you to run GK
clusters in a fully private fashion so
none of the GK workloads are actually
exposed publicly the GK knows themselves
do not even have a public IP address
everything is directly available over
the private network which is connected
to home Prem and at the same time this
allows them to run Jenkins on top of GK
while still being able to access the
artifacts turrets so in this way we made
we had a hybrid solution for this
customer by moving part of their CI CD
stack to the cloud while still being
able to connect to on Prem that's
interesting and I think it clarifies
that you do need to have a product and
networking understanding to know that
you can actually restrict access to
public endpoints for a private gke
cluster yeah yeah a networking
experience is always even people think
they move to the cloud they don't need
network engineers anymore but networking
knowledge is required even in the cloud
so let's talk about migrations now in
most cases migrations is a one-time
irreversible effort but with hybrid and
multi cloud and makes it so that you can
move in phases now so I think
portability here is key but let's say
I'm an organization I want to make my
workloads portable what would be my
first up to do that yeah so the the
first step is to make sure that your
workload is able to shift from one
computing platform to another platform
in order today that you need to separate
the application deployment and
management from the artifact of how you
deliver the software itself so there are
many tools that help you do that today
and based on these tools we can form a
tool chain that helps you do this for
any VM or container based workload that
you might have so I think key is in the
saying that making your workload
portable doesn't mean that you have to
make a cloud native this is often a
effort that is not significant to do and
people can start doing that today with
the tools available ok let's get
specific can you give me an example of a
tool chain that you can use to build VM
images and deploy to any cloud then
there are a few tools critical to search
the tool chain mostly for I would say
there is a CI system there is the image
builder there's the source version
control system and all these together
form a tool chain and allows you to
build images that can be deployed across
any platform so let me give an example
of how you would establish like what 2
is what you use for this to Jane so for
the image builder is a great open source
tool by her she core is called pecker
which takes in the application
deployment logic and a base image like
for example boom 2 or another Linux
system like rel and then build some
image that can be deployed across
different platforms but it's always
built using the same deployment script
so this really allows you to build
deployable images for any cloud platform
or on-premise system the other system is
the CI a system which job is really
taking the latest commits from the
source version control system and
building an image using the latest
application software and tying these
together allows you to build a pipeline
that that you can now build images
automatically for any platform whenever
a new commit gets pushed to the source
version control system that's really
it's the simple example of how you would
do it and most customers they should use
what they already familiar so if you're
using today Jenkins for CI is just
cutting using that however if you're
using other two you can easily plug and
play different tools to
built such a pipeline that toolchain
sounds really great for workloads that
have an automated way to deploy
applications in VMs but what if I have
an application in a VM already and I
want to deploy that to the cloud
yes that's that's actually a pretty
common scenario especially for large
enterprise that buy their software from
a vendor and that vendor gave them a
VMware image and at VMware image doesn't
have the applications separated from
image itself right so they have no way
of taking the application deploying it
on a higher base image that can be
deployed to another cloud so the only
solution is to take that VM as is and
somehow get it to the cloud so there are
two solutions at Google cloud offers
today to customers there's migrated for
compute engine which was previously
known as fellow strata which allows you
to take a VM SS and migrate to the cloud
and it has a lot of cool features you
can even migrate a VM with a tarts in
the original VM and test render
migration was successful so you can do
low risk vm i creation to the cloud the
other solution that i managed that I
mentioned is antle's migrate which
allows you to take a VM and convert it
to a container and run at container in
the cloud so both solutions allow you to
move workloads from home frame or other
cloud providers to Google Cloud so when
would you use one or the other none the
two solutions are different in what kind
of use case is support so and those my
grade is a solution that takes a VM and
converts it to container
and because that's a more sophisticated
technology it's more limited into what
kind of source workloads can support
migrate for compute engine on the other
hand allows you to migrate Mart's bigger
rains of workers I would say it support
most war-clubs that you can imagine in
these cases we're talking about
migrating existing VM workloads but what
if I want to create a standard for
creating portable applications that we
can move to any cloud yeah so that's
that's really where containers fit in
containers really forces the everyone
within the company to have a standard
that allows you to deploy the container
the same way in any environment however
if you start looking at how do I mean
it's a multi host environment you get
into more sophisticated area and it's
really rare kubernetes comes in so q
Brianna solves the chance of how can I
schedule containers across a host a set
of hosts in a cluster how can I do load
balancing across these containers how do
I ensure that I can scale out when
needed kubernetes has become the de
facto standard but is there any
difference in developer experience then
yeah definitely and that's including I
think improvement in developer
experience is always a good thing to
have so developers can really focus on
writing the code versus worrying about
where that code works volume production
and in development because they have the
same container that they build that also
gets using development but also gets
used in production so they're able to
improve their production reei ability by
having this kind of developer experience
I think it'd be helpful to jump into
another scenario let's say that I'm a
company and I've containerized some
applications but I'm still primarily
using monolithic applications on-premise
so how can I use Google tools to help
modernize import to the cloud we have a
modernization platform which we call
Antos which allows you to modernize your
applications either on primer in the
cloud it's based on open platform such
as kubernetes which we call end SDK sto
which we call endow service mares and K
native which we call cloud run and these
technologies really allow you to
modernize in place and move to the cloud
when you're ready what is an those look
like for IT ops versus developers what's
the user journey like when it comes to
migrating so I've been involved in a few
and those deployments and both all the
cases that I have been involved both
developers and the IT team have been
super inking it's actually not just IT
the networking team security team which
you could consider part of IT they have
all been super engaged especially during
the initial installation but also
afterwards for making sure that the
kubernetes platform the Endo's platform
stays running and up and making sure it
in developers have a proper experienced
IT operations is always gonna be
involved in those scenarios and
developers on the our end are going to
be focused on making sure their
workloads get up and running successor
eon kubernetes and make sure they stay
up and running
so they have different roles but they
are still both fully engaged yeah to
wrap up what are some of your views on
the trends for hybrid and multi club
yeah so I have seen no matter which kind
of customer work if you often see them
standardizing on kubernetes as the
platform for workloads to be running for
the future but also for current workers
to be migrated to and even industries
that are traditionally been slower to
adopt newer technologies they are also
starting to adopt kubernetes SD standard
for their internal applications and
external or any application so for those
people in that bucket what can they do
to get started and get some value out of
cloud today I think that the biggest
thing they should do is just get started
with a smaller pilot like find a workout
today wanted modernize right now get it
running on kubernetes see what a
benefits the game they gave you from
doing that and repeat that for other
workers as well but really some days
it's more just get it done and get
started
Sam thank you so much for being on the
show No thank you for having me it was
fun everyone check out the articles on
hybrid and multi cloud at the links
below and comment with your own
experience with it as well join us next
time for eyes on enterprise
[Music]